en 2012 une quarantaine de
mathématiciens de tout premier rang
collaborèrent à l' institute of advanced
studies à princeton
cette capitale des mathématiques qui a
vu passer tous les jours du 20e siècle
comme von neumann einstein gödel mail ou
encore whitten après un an de travail
acharné
une dream team de mathématiciens publia
un livre qui fera certainement date
ce livre est intitulé romo topic hype
théorie
son but redéfinir les fondements et
mathématiques sur des bases beaucoup
plus constructiviste est calculable de
sorte à faciliter les liens entre
mathématiques informatique à permettre
la vérification automatisée des preuves
mathématiques et à explorer plus
facilement et plus naturellement les
bizarreries de la théorie de l'omo topi
j'ai lu ce livre en entier
bon j'ai pas tout compris mais j'ai été
frappé par son élément arrêté et par sa
pédagogie puis surtout j'ai été séduit
je pense qu'il est grand temps de mettre
une bonne partie de la logique classique
en retrait et d'embrasser plus
pleinement la logique intuition nist
sous jacente à ce livre dont j'ai déjà
parlé dans l'épisode précédent de façon
grossière la spécificité de la théorie
des types comme de la logique intuition
nist et de se concentrer sur la notion
de fonction d'une certaine manière
alors que la théorie des ensembles était
une théorie d'objets et de lien entre
ces objets la théorie des types est une
théorie de ce qui peut être construit à
partir de briques élémentaires et de
règles de construction chaque
combinaison précise des règles de
construction donne alors lieu à une
fonction et ce qui est génial c'est que
de telles fonctions vont du coup
correspondre à des fonctions que les
ordinateurs sont capables de calculer la
théorie des types est ainsi remarquable
mot proche de la machine de turing dont
matt & magic vous a parlé dans cette
superbe vidéo et dont je vous ai parlé
avec le professeur rachid guerraoui sur
états baltes
ce qui est important à voir c'est qu'une
machine de turing ne possède qu'une
poignée de règles de manipulation
élémentaire
et pourtant si l'on spécifie
adéquatement comment combiner ces règles
de manipulation n'est capable
d'effectuer toutes sortes d'opérations
sophistiqué de votre application snap
chatte à la vidéo youtube que vous
regardez en passant par de
l'intelligence artificielle et des
simulations à grande échelle de notre
univers en fait de nombreux
informaticiens vont même jusqu à
postuler la fameuse thèse de church
turing qui dit en gros que notre univers
n'est qu'une immense machine de turing
bref toujours est il que la théorie des
types en tout cas sous sa forme la plus
élémentaire semble parfaitement adéquate
à l'étude des machine de turing
et au final c'est peut-être ça les
mathématiques ou en tout cas les
mathématiques intuition nist bien plus
que l'étude dénombre des formes ou des
structure algébrique c'est peut-être
davantage
l'étude des machine de turing mais
comment la théorie des types parvient
elle a étudié les machine de turing pour
le comprendre parlons des types
la distinction entre type est ensemble
est de prime abord pas si évidente tous
deux collectionne des éléments les
intuitivement un type correspond
davantage à une structure informatique
qu'un ensemble en particulier un type
viendra toujours accompagné de deux
types de fonctions la première est la
fonction de fabrication d'un élément du
type et la seconde est celle de
l'utilisation des éléments du type par
exemple en théorie des types on peut
construire le type end et entiers
naturels
il y a deux façons de construire un
élément de haine ou bien on utilise un
constructeur autonome qui va pondre un
élément de haine cet élément appelons le
zéro ou de bien on peut utiliser un
constructeur dit de succession qui va
pondre un élément de haine à partir d'un
autre élément de l
pour clore la définition de haine il
nous faut aussi évoqué l'utilisation que
l'on peut faire des éléments de haine
comment construire un élément d'un type
x à partir d'un élément n 2 n
pour ce faire on va utiliser la notion
de fonctions récursive cette fonction
récursive va requérir deux objets
définis au préalable
il va nous falloir un premier élément
x10 de type x ainsi qu'une fonction j'ai
qui transforme des éléments du type x en
d'autres éléments du type x le type
elle fournit alors une construction
d'une fonction ft finit par f20 est égal
à zéro et f2 est saine et égal alger 2
fm ainsi f-22 va être l'élément que nos
petits en partant de zéro et en
appliquant roger deux fois pour ceux qui
connaissent il s'agit d'une définition
par récurrence classique mais les
détails importe peu ce qui importe c'est
que le type elle nous fournit une façon
de construire des fonctions f à partir
d'objets gtx 0 c'est en cela que le type
n a plus de structures qu un ensemble
classique
il nous fournit des outils pour
construire des fonctions qui font
intervenir le type n
en particules on peut maintenant définir
la parité d'un nombre pour cela
considère un type à deux éléments parité
c'est à dire que ce type à deux
constructeurs autonome paires et
impaires
de plus on peut définir une fonction qui
utilise des éléments de parité en
précisant tout simplement les images de
pair et impair en particulier on peut
aisément définir une fonction inverse
parité de parité dans paris et qui
inverse la valeur de l'antécédent
autrement dit oppose inverse parité de
père est égal à un père est inverse
parité de 1 p r est égal à pair
on peut maintenant de définir une
fonction de calcul parité de hand en
parité qui calcule la parité d'un nombre
pour ce faire souvenez vous il nous faut
deux objets au préalable nous faut un
élément x0 de parité qui est l'image de
zéro on va bien sûr définir x 0 est égal
à pair ensuite il nous faut une fonction
j'ai qui va de parité dans parité on va
bien sûr utiliser la fonction j'ai été
dial à inverse parité le type n nous dit
alors que l'on peut construire une
fonction f
à partir de x 0 et j'ai une écrit ainsi
calcul parité est égal à ce que l'on
obtient à partir de paix rhdp de inverse
parité à travers ce que l'on appelle la
fonction d'induction du type n est tous
dans la théorie des types et construit
ainsi j'espère que vous voyez que dès
lors tout dans la théorie des types est
vraiment qu'une histoire de construction
est le plus intéressant c'est que même
les preuves sont des objets construire
plus précisément ce qui se passe est une
égalité de la forme x et viale y est en
fait un type éprouvé l'égalité revient à
construire un élément du type est là
elle est super important de distinguer
l'égalité propositionnelle souvent noté
avec le symbole égale classique de
l'égalité définitionnelle que je vais
noter ici avec le symbole trip légal
ainsi lorsque j'ai écrit calcul parité
égale induction par rapport à n d objets
père est inverse parité j'ai utilisé le
symbole trip légale car il s'agit là
d'une définition de l'objet calcul
parité en particulier si je reconstruise
est un nouvel objet mais selon la même
construction et que je lui donne un
autre nom par exemple si je posais f est
égal à l'induction par rapport à n
de père et de inverse parité et voire
même si j'écrivais f est égal à
l'induction par rapport à n 2 x 0 et 2 g
où ils 0 est par définition père et j'ai
été égale par définition à inverse
parité alors on aurait une égalité
définitionnelle par construction
des objets f et calculs parité tout ça
parce que au fond ces deux objets sont
construits de la même manière l'égalité
définitionnelle ne correspond pas un
type mais comme on peut s'y attendre si
deux objets sont égaux par construction
alors ils vont être égaux de façon
propositionnelle autrement dit quand on
a une égalité définitionnelle on peut en
déduire un élément de l'égalité
propositionnelle associés parce que par
construction calcul parité et f sont
égaux ils sont égaux de façon
définitionnelle alors je peut en déduire
l'existence d'un objet souvent noté
réflexion de calcul parité qui
appartient au type calcul parité est
égal à f et ce qui est alors très
pratique c'est que l'on peut maintenant
manipuler les éléments d'un type
d'égalité pour construire d'autres
éléments
par exemple il ya un torrent très
important en théorie des types qui dit
qu' étant donné n'importe quelle
fonction f
on peut toujours construire une fonction
apf qui a tout élément de x égale y
associe un élément de fgx est égal à
elle de y est on peut ré interpréter ça
selon la logique comme étant le fait
qu'étant donné une preuve
x est égal à y apf va construire une
preuve de h2x est égal à elle de y
et ça ça nous permet d'avoir une toute
nouvelle lecture des fondements de la
logique
ainsi la fonction ap de f correspond à
une implication
elle permet de déduire de x et hey ya
les grecs le fait que f 2 x est égal à
f2 y
en fait en théorie des types une
fonction est ni plus ni moins une
implication
mieux encore la théorie des types fait
table rase des opérateurs logique du
passé dont on a parlé dans l'épisode 13
et ne s'intéressent désormais plus qu'à
des fonctions et à des objets que l'on
peut construire
ainsi au lieu de dire pour toute haine
pour tout m n + m est égal à hem plus
saine la théorie des types va chercher à
construire une fonction qui lorsqu'on
lui donne un entier n est un entier m
construit un élément du type
enplus m est égal à haisnes plus elle
une telle fonction est assez inhabituel
en logique classique puisque son type
d'arrivée dépend de son hymne tout on
parle de fonctions dépendantes et on
note f
étant un objet du produit pour n
appartenant à haisnes du produit pour m
appartenant à n2n puce m est égal à hem
plus saine c'est super bizarre au début
mai
au bout d'un certain temps on finit par
trouver sa jolie j'ai fini par trouver
sa jolie de la même manière la formule
logique il existe n tels que pour tout m
n + m est égal à m se traduit en théorie
des types par le type somme pour n
appartenant à haisnes du produit pour
les m appartenant à n 2 n + m est égal à
m
et un élément z de ce type est une perle
z est égal à xfx et l'entier naturel
dont on cherche à prouver l'existence et
f être qu'une fonction qui appartient au
type le produit pour les m appartenant à
n 2 x poussé m est égal à hem c'est à
dire que f nous fournit des preuves que
xp m est égal à m pour tout élément m 2
n bref comme vous pouvez l'imaginer j'ai
été très très très incomplet dans cette
vidéo on peut pas résumer un livre de
480 pages d'un tel niveau dans une vidéo
de 10 minutes et il y aurait encore
beaucoup beaucoup à dire sur la théorie
des tic en particulier toutes les
mathématiques classiques peuvent être
étudiées dans la théorie de type même
une fois que l'on a admis l'axiome du
nid valence
modulo l'ajout de certaines règles de
construction mais ce que j'espère
vraiment si que vous ayez senti ce qui
m'a séduit dans cette théorie des types
d'azun fin on a parlé des mathématiques
intuition liste et de certains aspects
assez bizarre de cette théorie que je
trouve personnellement absolument
fascinant au fus milo nous demande s'il
ya un moyen de lier les mathématiques
classique et les mathématiques intuition
nist la réponse est oui en fait dans un
fc il est possible de créer un modèle
qui satisfasse les actions de la logique
classique en particulier dans lequel le
tiers exclu
vrai ou faux notamment on peut parler de
machine de turing à l'intérieur de ces
dames c est l inverse en mathématiques
constructiviste on peut avoir des sous
partie de l'univers où certains des
types par exemple de la théorie des
types satisfont exactement l'axiome du
choix et je tiens exclus et tout ce que
vous voulez je vous renvoie vers un
excellent billet de blogue d'andré mba
obame qui parle de cela notamment theo
zimmerman me fait remarquer que j'ai
affirmé que deux hommes de kunter
bernstein était faux alors que c'est pas
vrai en fait il est juste indécidable
tout à fait raison si on se place dans
la logique inflationniste où on ne fait
que ne pas supposer que l'ex-homme du
choix est vrai retire un axiome de des
mathématiques classique en retirant cet
axiome non on peut pas prouver des trucs
qui sont incompatibles avec le cas où
l'axiome est vrai tout ce que l'on peut
prouver c'est que certains théorème non
plus de preuve ne peuvent plus être
déduits sans faire appel à l'action du
choix ou le tir exclus et en effet le
terme de cantorbery stein ne devient pas
faux mais indécidable en logique anti
sioniste ceux ci étant dit qu'ils ont
quand ce à dire que le nombre
constructivité fosses dire on a le droit
de construire que des fonctions de
calcul en particulier quelques par
machine de turing notamment quand on se
place dans une logique très très
constructive à ce moment là le théorème
de canterbury stein devient faut en
particulier le message important de la
vidéo précédente
c'est qu'il ya des choses que l'on
considère vrai mais qui sont faux si on
fait une hypothèse un petit peu
différente mais qui à mon sens c'est pas
du tout farfelu savoir que toute
fonction doit être calculable bc dwarf
créé d'autres 97 et pas mal d'autres
parmi vous ont signalé dans les
commentaires qui n'ont pas été
convaincus par la vidéo précédente
il s'agit pas de vous prouver que les
mathématiques constructives sont les
vrais mathématiques et que les
mathématiques classiques sont fausses ou
erronées ou quoi que ce soit il s'agit
de deux ma thématique différente et j'ai
envie de vous sorti à une autre citation
de points car elle qui disait que la
géométrie
n'est pas vrai elle est juste
avantageuse et j'ai envie de dire que
c'est la même chose pour les
mathématiques en général des
mathématiques n'ont rien de vrai de faux
s'agit pas d'un débat de savoir qui a
raison mais il s'agit de savoir est ce
que c'est les outils que même des
mathématiques constructif pourrait être
plus pertinente dans certains contextes
pour certains objectifs
parce qu'elles peuvent être plus
avantageuses que les mathématiques
classique pour certains problèmes -
voire peut-être même pour toute la
physique je vous dis à la question de
chez storck et à qui nous demande si on
est des machines turing il y as en
informatique une thèse très connu qui
s'appelle la thèse de church turing
beaucoup d'informaticiens croire la
thèse de torchis turing il ya même
parfois des réfutations de certaines
théories physiques
juste parce qu'elle viole le la thèse de
torture est niée permettent par exemple
de résoudre le prêtre de l'arrêt bref si
vous dis tout ça c'est que la thèse de
doctorat futuring c'est quelque chose de
vraiment fiable aujourd'hui parce que
beaucoup de gens y croient et si la
thèse de church turing est vrai ça veut
dire que tout dans notre univers est
forcément calculable et en particulier
que les mathématiques qui sont
pertinentes à notre univers sont les
mathématiques des machine de turing donc
des mathématiques ultra constructive en
silo 8 dire c'est faire des
mathématiques dans laquelle il accuse le
tir exclus et fo auquel cas peut-être
que les maths constructives sont plus
avantageuses que les maths classique
clément le loup nous demande si les
mathématiques constructives sont
capables de nous parler de nombreux
irrationnelle mois en fait oui par
exemple pis écrit comme la formule
suivante
on avait vu dans le premier épisode de
ce forum le 4 - 4/3 puisqu'elle serait
qu'ils aiment et ainsi de suite à
l'infini et ça on peut voir ça comme si
on prend les justes les haines premier
terme une approximation du nombre pi et
en fait on peut même calculé à quel
point l'approximation et justes et donc
à partir de cette formule il est assez
facile de construire une machine de
turing un algorithme le code
informatique qui va calculer une
approximation de pi à une décimale ou à
1 sur rennes près une appréciation de pi
à plus ou moins 1 sur rennes à partir de
cette forme et c'est assez immédiat
c'est même très facile et bien en
mathématiques constructive
c'est ce code informatique ce code qui
nous fournit des approximations de pi
qui est égal appliquez une construction
de pi bien sûr il ya d'autres
algorithmes complètement différents qui
vont construire également pi et parfois
on peut prouver que deux algorithmes
différents en fait la même valeur de
peace ou égal à quelqu'un on pourra
avoir une égalité propositionnelle entre
deux machines nature et non plus tôt
entre deux éléments de type des réelles
qui n'est pas une égalité définition
enfin grosse indique shiv et au fus milo
me demande d'expliquer le théorème que
j'avais mentionné à la fin de la vidéo
précédente à savoir le fait qu'en
logique et antisioniste toutes les
fonctions sont continus toutes les
fonctions réelles sont continues est
assez facile de penser à un autre
exemple qui apparaît beaucoup plus
simple de discontinuité par exemple la
fonction qui vaut aux héros pour une
ombre strictement négatif et qui vaut un
point un nombre supérieur ou égal à zéro
et si vous voyez le problème avec cette
définition une fois que je l'écris comme
ça c'est qu'on a à une disjonction de
cas et que l'on suppose
lorsqu'on écrit cette définition que
l'on va forcément à tomber dans l'un ou
l'autre cas bien logique anti sioniste
il est possible que aucun de ces deux
cas ne soit probablement vrai pour
nombre réel x donné donné par une
machine de turing parce qu'en logique
constructive
notamment ce qu'on pense que les nombres
réels sont des machine de turing qui
donne des approximations d'une réelle en
question on n'a accès qu'aux
approximations du num en question donc
si on avait une machine naturelle qui
dont les approximations amd wayne
premières décimales lui disent que c'est
0,00 0,00 ne peut pas savoir si il va y
avoir un a ou si ça va finir pas être en
fête - 000 on ne peut pas savoir le
signe de x tant qu' on n'a pas testé un
infini toutes les approximations fini du
non moins x sauf que avec une machine de
turing
on ne peut pas tester toutes les
apprenants et les approximations à
l'infini d'une autre machine de turing
c'est à rien aux pointes de l'arrêt ton
passé ans vous a parlé dans cet épisode
du coup il ya disons ctions de cas qui
nous a permis de définir une fonction
discontinue ici on n'a pas le droit de
la faire en maths constructive et
notamment lorsqu on peut dire que
nombres réels sont des machine de turing
qui ont certaines propriétés est en fait
en mode constructive
il se passe un truc que je trouve assez
génial c'est que l'ensemble des réelles
forme vraiment un conte ignoble qu'il
est très difficile qui est même
impossible de couper le on a vraiment à
un continuum insécables c'est quelque
chose qui est très qui a pas vraiment de
pendant en mathématiques classique et
qui pourtant est une structure qui donne
envie d'être étudiée qui suscite en tout
cas ma curiosité et c'est le fait que
l'ensemble des nombreux réel soit aussi
continue beaucoup plus continue quand
logique classique qui fait que les
fonctions qu'ils manipulent ces nombres
réels vont devoir forcément être
continue elle aussi parce que ne peuvent
pas séparés comme ça ne peuvent pas
couper la droite des réelles franchement
si ça ça vous fascine pas c'est pas des
matelas et j'espère que vous avez aimé
cette vidéo c'était l'avant dernière de
la série sur infinie nous reste plus
qu'une seule qui va parler d'un axiome
ultra moderne
axiome du nid valence a de vladimir vote
ce qui brille fields et après cette
série sur l'infini on va commencer une
nouvelle série de vidéos
alors je vous avais dit que vous donnera
l'opportunité de voter pour le thème de
la prochaine série en fait c'était un
mensonge
finalement j'ai décidé dictatorialement
de vous parler d'un thème qui me tient à
coeur et qui sera beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus compréhensible que cette
série sur l'infini qui va être aussi dit
pas trop si vous avez aimé cet épisode
penser à de l'ikea le commentaire de
partage et pensez à vous abonner pour ne
pas manquer les futurs épisodes merci
aussi pour leurs dons et j'espère que je
verrai la prochaine fois dans la
communauté mathématique la machine de
turing universelle était très symbolique
car ont réalisé une est une manière de
démontrer qu'on pourrait simuler tout ce
qu'on dit maintenant vers sont publiés
deux sauteurs de ce passage on vous
revoit qui ne mentionne pas la théorie
au mot logique bourbaki époux prudent
pour ne dit pas de faire dériver toute
la mathématique il écrit de faire
dériver presque toute la matière natif
actuelle d'une source ine la
théorisation